que cette cathédrale c'est la mère de
notre dame à chalais pas non et pourquoi
à votre avis la cathédrale de sens et la
mère de notre dame
c'est probablement la première
cathédrale gothique j'imagine c'est un
joyau du patrimoine bourguignon
construite à partir de 1135 soit 30 ans
avant notre dame de paris
saint-etienne de sens et la première
cathédrale gothique du monde pour s'en
rendre compte il suffit de contempler la
nef
on connaît pas le nom de l'architecte
pour l'appel lemaitre 200 au premier
matrix qu'il a innové et bien il a dû
beaucoup voyagé garder les bonnes idées
des pays anglo normand il est génial sur
les peelings soit porteur grâce à cela
la croisée de gym les forces cool sont
les piliers les murs sont plus porteurs
je peux faire de grandes ouvertures un
art nouveau et n'est qu'on appelle l'art
de france à l'époque et plus tard l'art
gothique au 12e siècle
l'archidiocèse de sang c'était la
capitale religieuse du royaume de france
à l'époque celle architecture romane qui
étaient à la mode mais un archevêque
sénonais a voulu casser les codes en
réclamant un édifice grandiose et
novateur donc nous sommes devant un des
plus beaux vitraux de cathédrale de sens
à vitrac début xiiie siècle dans une
forêt du 12e siècle et c'est bien le
signe général de sens
on voit toute l'évolution du gothique le
premier jusqu'au flamboiement du
gothique à la fin des années 1500 comme
notre dame la cathédrale de sens
possédait deux tours et une flèche
centrale une flèche aujourd'hui disparu
mais les ressemblances ne s'arrêtent pas
là avec l'incendié d'un train de paris
on a beaucoup parlé des fameux arc
boutant hors les voilà les premiers
habitants et sont l'oeuvre du maître de
sens grâce à lui on a pu élever le cadre
à l'eau plus haut et c'est pour ça qu'on
peut dire que sans cette manière de ce
point de vue là est la mère de notre
dame de paris par cette technique
donc c'est normal qu actuellement la
maire de paris
en quelque sorte se penche sur cette île
morte riz
du haut de ses neuf cent ans ce grand
témoin de l'art gothique pourrait
inspirer les architectes pour la
reconstruction de notre dame la
cathédrale mer pourrait alors assister à
la renaissance de sa fille bien aimée